[Music]
these insects have been growing
underground for 17 years they're
annoying creepy and above all noisy
these are cicadas and soon millions of
them will erupt from underground causing
chaos to everything around them now what
if you suddenly got surrounded by them
what would a plague of cicadas do to
your body are they lethal to humans and
how could they affect your hearing
hearing hearing hearing this is what if
and here's what would happen if you were
attacked by a swarm of cicadas these
insects that spend 17 years underground
are known as periodical cicadas and they
almost never come in small doses
when they're finally born there's 1.5
million of them per acre of land and in
a single forest there can be hundreds of
millions of them
so what would happen if you are caught
in the middle of all these cicadas the
first thing you'd notice with millions
of cicadas around you would be their
incredibly loud mating call a single
cicada can be as loud as a lawnmower now
imagine how loud millions of them would
be it's common for people who live in
areas with lots of cicadas to wear some
sort of hearing protection even if
you're far away from them you would
still notice their noise so if millions
of them suddenly bombarded you it would
be like being in the middle of a rock
concert if you're in this cloud of
insects for long enough they'd likely
damage your hearing
not to mention that you'd be incredibly
annoyed worst concert ever and speaking
of which a cicadas body is very similar
to a guitar since their abdomens are
hollow like a guitar the sound gets
amplified and can spread further and be
even louder now that you're hearing is
damaged you'd likely be suffering from
the pain unable to move as you're lying
there the cicadas would continue to fly
around you some of them may pierce into
your skin and suck on your blood but
this isn't intentional the cicadas are
just mistaken you for a tree since their
primary food source comes from trees
drinking your blood would kill the
cicada so you shouldn't expect too many
bites from see the thing is cicadas are
really really dumb I mean can you blame
them
they've been growing underground for 17
years and when
merge they have virtually zero brain
power and very few motor skills this
would cause millions of them to stumble
and bump into you you could probably
squished thousands of them by accident
just by walking and because these
insects are so clumsy
it makes them easy pickings for lots of
different animals so not only would you
be swarmed by cicadas but you could
expect other critters like chipmunks
raccoons and birds to be near you as
well they'd all be feasting off the
cicadas for weeks until there were
practically none left and as that's
happening you should be able to make
your escape granted you'd have some
injuries but this is a scenario where
it's possible you'd make it out alive
after all these cicadas aren't trying to
hurt you they're just dumb and really
annoying they're mainly a food source
for other animals and every summer those
creatures can feast in the forest so
although they might not be our favourite
insect we should probably keep
periodical cicadas alive but what else
could we safely make extinct maybe
mosquitoes well that sounds like a story
for another what if
[Music]
you